hello everyone and welcome back to the
chest 24 legends of chess tournament
it's vishwanathan
vs vladimir kramnik two of the legends
that are still
uh very active in the chess world uh
kramnik is officially retired from
from classical chess but he still uh
comes around here and there to play a
a rapid or blitz tournament and even
though the two of them
uh had their real clash in 2018 born in
germany
uh in their wheelchair championship
match now in 2020 they face each other
again
in an online tournament so this game uh
as the rustam kasim jhanov said in the
in the live uh
uh coverage is the legend in itself and
i think the only
the only real problem with this game is
that it was played in uh well you know
in a rapid
game online instead of uh instead of a
beautiful classical setting although
okay we would not
get all of these positions on the board
if this was an actual classical game
uh but still it's really uh it's really
a marvelous game and uh
let's check it out hope you guys enjoy
it so on and with the white pieces opens
with e4
sorry about that uh we have e6 by
kramnik going for the french defense uh
and now
d4 uh we have d5 by kramnik knight to c3
and here we have
knight to f6 now going for the classical
variation of the french with e5
advancing the pawn
so the stein its variation and the
knight after d7 preparing to strike in
the center with c5
with f4 which makes sense you want to
help out with the defense of the center
as you are expecting c5
so c5 by black we have knight to f3 and
knight to c6 so both players are very
naturally developing
uh bishop to e3 and now bishop to e7 uh
we have queen to d2 by anand
and now a6 preparing b for uh b5
and of course b4 so bishop to d3
uh and here b5 now preparing to to push
the pawn all the way to b4
uh and now comes a3 and here a lot of
moves uh have been played in this
position most often queen b6 and bishop
to b7 but here the move kramnik plays
is a new move in the position and no
doubt something he prepared for this
game so he pushes the
very anti-positional c4 of course after
a3
uh he pushes this this a very
anti-positional c4 move
uh which uh usually is not a problem for
white as you no longer
uh you're no longer actively involved in
the fight for the central squares and
the white will
make use of that so hopefully so bishop
back to e2 and now
knight to b6 uh we have castles by on
and uh
and now bishop to d7 so still just
developing pieces
and bishop to d1 and it makes room for
uh
his knight on the d1 on the e2 square in
the future it can be shifted to g3 or
maybe
this pawn can come to f5 and then knight
to f4 all depending on what black plays
so here we have g6
gaining more control of the f5 square
and now h3
uh we have queen to c7 again continuing
development probably preparing to castle
queenside
and bishop to f2 now preparing to trade
off the dark square bishops via this
bishop to h4 idea with h6 by
kramnik and now comes knight to e2 now
this knight can also be shifted
to the king side but you also want to
play c3 here to prevent
any future b4 ids so a5 bichromnic
and now comes c3 uh and a queen side
castle
uh here uh anand goes for this bishop to
h4 move he wants to trade off the dark
square bishops
uh we have bishop captures knight
captures and now king to b7 just getting
the king to a safer square
knight back to f3 and now rook to a8
rook to a8 is a very a very
weird move but weird for me
but i will i will mention y so here we
have queen
bishop to c2 by anand and now queen to
d8
we have g4 now uh starting the expansion
on the king side
and this is a a very uh well thematic uh
thing in this game so here you have
anand who castled a short on the king
side
and he is expanding on the king side and
you have kramnik that castled queen side
and he is pushing on the queen side
so usually when you have castles on
opposite sides of the board you you want
to attack
uh the enemy king where he castle you
don't want to
open up lines in front of your own king
but this is exactly what
this game is about so here we have queen
to e7 by kramnik
and now knight the g3 preparing to push
even further
at some point maybe even with f5 uh but
now we have b4 so kramnik again who
castled
queen side pushes on the queen side with
a captures a captures and now
uh a rook trait on the queen side
captures captures and
now uh f5 so anand says okay if you're
gonna push
where you castled i'm gonna push where
where i castle my own king
so here we have g captures on f5 g
captures on f5 and now
rook to a2 here just going after this uh
b2 pawn so of course anand defends it we
have queen to c1
uh and now b captures on c3 with b
captures on c3 and
queen to a3 here kramnik goes for the c3
pawn but also offers a queen trade
uh anand says okay we can trade but
first bishop to b1
now my queen is guarding the c3 pawn and
uh what
what are you gonna do here uh kramnik
trades queens as this is what uh what he
intended to do with queen captures
rook captures and now rook to b2
preparing to bring the rook over to b3
to attack the pawn
and also it can be joined with this
knight for example knight a4 going after
the c3 pawn
uh and here f6 anand says okay you have
a light square bishop there
with all of your pawns on light squares
and me locking the position with f6 that
will be
a useless piece and okay we have knight
to a for now going after the b3 pawn now
you can
support the attack for example with rook
to b3 but
now bishop to h7 now anand spots a very
sneaky idea
here you could go for rook to b3 but you
can also defend it with knights to e2 so
it's not that big of a deal
so here we have knight to a5 bringing
the knight over to b3
and well you could attack this pawn from
this square
anand decides to do it from g6 he wants
to keep the bishop on this diagonal
as the bishop uh can't be captured
either way if you capture the bishop
just f7 and there is no defense
against f8 queening so after bishop g6
with
knight the b3 here kramnik says i'm not
very impressed by your pawn there so
just move your rook
and even if you go for something like
bishop captures an f7 knight captures on
c1
and bishop moves uh you will not be able
to uh
to promote this pawn because after the
king moves you can push the pawn but now
just rook here and the rook guards the
f8 square
so not not an issue for uh for black so
instead after knight the b3 will rook
the e1 by anand
and now comes bishop to e8 just
defending that guy there
and now comes a beautiful attacking move
by anand uh
knight to f5 just just spectacular going
after this h6 pawn
saying that okay if you if you capture
my knight uh then i just win the game
with e6 there's
really not much you can do here uh if
you capture it
i'm just going to capture bishop and
promote this pawn
to a queen and even if you don't capture
it i don't really care whatever you do
let's say knight captures on c3 just e
captures on f7 and
after this uh here is traded off this
bishop can just be moved and you're
gonna push the f pawn to victory
so here after knight to f5 we have f
captures on g6
and now now comes knight to d6 with
check as now this check
forks the king and the bishop and you
win back your piece so here we have king
to c7
and now knight captures on e8 with chuck
preserving the past
f6 pawn so king d7 and now knight back
to d6
and here uh well it seems like you're
very close here
once the pawn is actually pushed the
king can come to e7 and block the
f8 square so here g5 by kramnik not
allowing knight to h4 to go after this
because then you really if the knight
would land here
then from g6 you would have very nice
support of this as the knight would
cover the f8 square
but here uh there is again another
beautiful move for anand uh so feel free
to pause the video and try to find it uh
well i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the knight needs to go back to f5 yet
again and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's knight to f5 and
now
you are going after the h6 pawn and
there is nothing uh black can do about
it so this pawn is gonna fall this pawn
is gonna fall and then this pawn is
definitely queening so king the e8 uh
kramnik knows that there's no stopping
this so he he he might as well
help out with the defense of the dfa
square
so knight captures on h6 and now comes
knight captures on c3 kramny creates a
pass pawn of his own and it's already a
fast pawn on c4
knight captures on g5 and now knight
captures on d4
creating yet another pass pawn so who
who will have a a faster pass pawn so
here we have f7 with
check king the e7 and luckily for
kramnik the f8 square
is not yet covered but if you allow
something like knight to h7 and
f8 it's definitely game over so one way
to do it
would be well of course if you go knight
stage seven right away then knight to f3
check
uh and uh there there's a you're either
getting mated for example king h1 and
rook to h2 is checkmate
or if you go to f1 then you can always
go for a perpetual knight to h2 checking
here knight here with check and you will
never be able to queen that pawn
so knight to h7 although very appealing
doesn't really work so here
rook to f1 is one option uh the
again defending the f3 square and just
threatening to
win and it is the most straightforward
way to win anand chooses a different way
he plays rook to a1 his idea is rook to
a7 check king here then another check
king will move somewhere and then you
promote the pawn to a queen
all with tempo however now we have
knight
seat e2 with check king f2 and now you
you are in the face of a nasty discovery
so knight to f4
check with all of this maneuvering
kramnik finds a way to get his knight
all the way to
g6 so king g3 and knight to g6 now
guarding the f8 square
uh rook to a7 with check king to d8
uh and now rook to a8 with check we have
king to c7
and now comes uh rook to g8 uh just
going after that knight
uh now you're threatening to pick it up
and just uh win the game uh you could
all
you could also just push the pawn but
you don't want to win the knight you
want to get a queen into the game
because
black's past pawns are extremely
dangerous here
so rook the g8 going after the knight
and now knight to e2
with check we have king to f2 attacking
the knight again going into the face of
the discovery but
uh there there is a there isn't anything
much better so
knight's the e4 again with a discovered
check
king to e3 and now c3 kramnik starts
pushing his own passport as well
but now now comes knight captures on e6
with
check also a possibility was just rook
captures here because after knight
captures you could go for knight
captures on e6 with the check
king d7 and then bring the knight back
to f4 and try and play this
the knight can come back to d3 and help
out with the defense of the c1 square
but anand chooses a different path he
goes for knight captures an e6 check
right away
knight captures and now rook captures on
g6 again with the same idea threatening
to pick this
knight up and promote the pawn but now
d4
with check we have kinked e4 and now
comes
rook to e2 with check it's a very
complicated position
but c2 was winning here for kramnik
because
after the c2 move you get captures and
even though both players get a queen
into the game
uh white is getting checkmated or will
suffer severe material loss for example
queen e3 check you're gonna go king d5
and now queen b3
there's no defending the rook and even
after you move here just uh this check
uh the king cannot cross the third rank
you're gonna go here
check uh pics of the queen even the rook
with check
and that's game over for for white
uh but uh the time is ticking this is a
rapid game and of course
there is no time to calculate uh such
lines that's what i meant in the
beginning of the video
uh when i said that the the only you
know thing that's wrong with this game
is that it's not a really long classical
game so here
rook to e2 instead by kramnik with check
king of three going after the rook now
rook
e3 check king g4 and now knight to f8
finally getting the knight out of harm's
way
rook to g8 going after the knight and
now knight back to d7 again you can
promote but
black will gladly give up a night for
this past pawn
and here we have f5 uh with uh
knight to f5 just attacking the rook
here
but kramnik says this is exactly what i
was waiting for
uh c2 and here now there is no stopping
kramnik's promotion of the queen knight
captures an e3 was played and now
c1 queen kramnik is the first to bring
the queen into the game
knight to d5 with check and now king to
b7 and now
e6 and now it's very dangerous two
connected past pawns versus a queen
not uh not uh the the easiest thing to
play with black we have queen to d1
check by kramnik and now king to g5
and now there are of course uh many
squares where
one might check the white king uh
however kramnik chooses the
the absolute worst square he plays queen
to d to check
and now the problem with this move is
that it completely loses the game but
it's not
easy to spot especially in uh with a few
seconds on the clock why it loses
but you're comfortable in your own homes
uh or you know somewhere
uh feel free to pause the video and win
this game for anand
well i'll give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the knight and f4 guards any squares
where the black queen might deliver
checks such as this
uh also blocks the queen here uh you
could go for queen to a5 check which is
the nicest one uh but now
now you're just threatening to pick up
the knight and then
bring your own queen into the game so
let's see what happens if you can start
checking let's say checking g6
and now you could go for queen b6 uh
pinned the pawn and you don't really
care if
this pawn queens you're just going to
capture it with the knight so king
g7 now again saying i'm still gonna just
capture here in queen the pawn but
there is there is no move here whatever
black plays let's say d3 you're gonna
capture the knight and now after a few
more checks
are delivered king g6 queen e4 check
you're gonna go king g5
uh queen to e7 with check you're gonna
go
uh king to h6 and now there are no more
useful checks after one more is given
knight blocks
and again this is covered by the knight
this is covered by the knight and there
are no more checks you're either
queening this pawn or
if queen captures then you're queening
this pawn so this
is how anand wins unfortunately for
anand uh with few seconds on the clock
he did not spot knight to f4 he played
king to g6 but now vladimir just played
queen to g2 with
check and it was in this position almost
63.
yes it's it's a shame that it was on
move 63 not on
64. that vishwanathan anand resigned the
game and game one of their match in the
chest 24 legends of chess
goes to vladimir kramnik so here you
resign because
after the king moves you are going to
eliminate the knight and then nothing is
protecting uh those important squares
for example king h7 you're just gonna
grab the knight
and now while you could play e7 and hope
for
something there really isn't much to
hope for you can either capture on f7
with
check or you can even go for a nice
mating attack as it is a force maze
queen h5
check king here you're gonna go queen g5
check the knight covers d
square soaking back knight f6 check here
and now this is just checkmate
so of course anand sawdus and he said
all right here
i will resign so really
a spectacular game uh like i said the
only
wrong thing with this game is that it's
it's a rapid game played online and not
some classical game played in uh
some beautiful tournament uh because
this game would
definitely you know uh be heading for
for
a lot of books if if you know book
sanchez will still be written
uh but yeah uh that's uh the game i do
hope you enjoyed it uh so many of you
have already uh
requested it even though it just
finished i would like to thank bryce
foster
ross martin michael pilgaard adam
nicholas and simon heath for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the uh
legends of chess uh continuing to check
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day